special teams dominated game for Dallas in a four
nothing Victory here's baly walking in with a
shot that one glanced off Wedgewood and off to the
glass and it's Ste leaned on by lqu D Center's got
through a chance Wedgewood with some contact made
the save and with an open net lost his stick he
made a great blocker save and then this one here
to was in front of the into the middle of the ice
Robertson for Handley down low tapped and
it's fought off by B improve the team speed
and really activate the weak side to get more of
a fourman attack up the ice instead of basically
a three on five here's the alleo for hin he
able to time it right Robertson shoots and
scores and here's the high flip out there it
took a funny bounce and uh you know timing of
this was uh very difficult from my vantage
point you might have had a better look on
your side but let's oh boy now obviously
that's a deceiving look right there the
NHL will have that from the camera level I
I'm I'm going to say that when we look at
that above the blue line and not across it
and of course uh you know whether it's col
and camel and oh it's a quick one ker in the
in Toronto after reviewing the play the play
was determined to be offside no goal he's
got Keen hockey sense he's he's admitted
that he's worked on some conditioning
to improve at this leveli in shoots and
storms this one will count
Joe pavelski one- nothing
Dallas across the grain here on the
rer he just fires this up under the
bar and in and here he looks it off
looks one way no chance to get it to
Robertson fires it high there's
that rer turns the right hand
over Young Star defenseman for the Minnesota W
but gave it away to Marksman banked on here's
Duane with a Chance ball at the Save The
Rebound kick back away from the goal save
that we're talking about here good bank pass
there Duan tries to drag that Puck and go to
The Far Side good here making a couple of
saves that one ankled to the front and they
score a buny Hop Off the Wall hit the eigh of
the goal and Matt new Shan flutters it into the
net and it's two nothing puckin up in the net
but here's the play around the board and and
it just surprised him that was a very active
bounce I'm sure he's expecting this to go all
the way around but it was perfectly placed and
uh obviously the rebound pops out and watch do
Shane come in here F boy he just you know I
mean you talked about a a perfect play for a
shooter to come in there and then it's a wobbly
po kind of rolled off the end of his blade Su a
wild player on him Johansson gotf free flips
it over it was airborne and they hit it off
the post a backhand chop from Brock faver heading
to the net that first opportunity here Johansson
right there to Middleton and this one goes
off the bar in the back Ender two defenseman
Faber and Middleton right there Tri to drag
it away Shane leaned on by Faber still with
it and tried to sneak it short side on wallad hit
the outside of the post 17 left on the matching
miners no penalty there as that shot from mermis
wouldn't go long feet ahead gloved
down by Marksman across for hon he
scores four on four goals R hin Dallas lead is
now three nothing up and then the goal down the
other way and a nice little pass and you see
hin just kind of pushes it ahead just slides
his past the stick s just a little push
in motion touched it so noan pass Baldi
off STI of P this one will flank off the glass
behind the of wed handled by Eric sck out high
for Faber R shot scores roock Faber may have
been deflected along the way and one finally
beat Scott Wedgewood that Baldi I I I think 12
got it outside the blue line going to play Down
Low by ericon and right there when he pulls it
back and it goes off the back end I I believe
a a Baldi I I think it went off his numbers
oh and it wasn't as close as I thought it was
there as he pulled that back and got a lot on
it and it just glances off the number one or
right around the stripe of the pants right there
right in the top Corner in Center Lun Twist Off
The Glass took a hop kept in gagoski Marco rosi
rest shot off the post now Johansson tried to
go to the net it was slowed up and crept wide
way to get it through and that this close to
being a one goal game no one in the NHL other
than him has played 5 30 plus minute games in
season favors on the ice of the only man back
for a two-on one Robertson and donov Robertson
scores Jason Robertson restores
the three-goal lead for
Dallas going up the boards by Lindell and then
long stick of Robertson and he's just got such
a slippery wrer I mean it's just on his blade
and looks like he handle it right on the toe of
the blade and then he just snaps it in one quick
motion it just looks rather unassuming until you
see the end results deadly accurate and you see
favor was in but when Glen Hall told me that he
wanted the defenseman to to force him early so
that everybody knows what page you're on I hard
to argue with that guy good point here's list
he scores bills list has made it 51 Dallas with
two goals in a minute and 21 seconds for the
stars and flipper right there by mermis it's
picked off through the neutral zone nice little
play there by foxa the defenseman comes comes up
from behind as you can see that's a nice little
move against good and then there's Lundquist with
the rer and right oh boy those are tough ones
right underneath threw the elbow off maybe the
side of the body and angles it out zcell the
Baldi BDI straight away zuk carello back door
and they score what a what a look yeah zukar
to Hartman and a five on three power play goal
for Minnesota well one of the issues in that
last game was the puck didn't go through zc
Carell in one timer there Baldi plays it over
to zukar he's looking fake shot the whole way
and he's looking for the right-hander on the
far side and that's Harman he's going to jam
this one home you see you've got Eric right in
the middle of the ice his way down Liney again
stops X spun to the net and that one cleared up
and I thought it hit the netting Mason marman B
behind the net loose Puck available there but go
wins the race but marman came over challenge him
marman took the puck away s scor that happened
in muray Marchman sets up Tyler San for his
16 starts up high goes down low good work
by Steel and that point there the wild
have possession of that puck bosan swarmed
and then this shot here in the quiet area
of the ice he's able to stop it get control
double digit goal scores in the NHL Vancouver
the other but Dallas is the only one that
has seven fors double go looking for more
that one knocked away this one set down on the
back door and they add number seven to their
tally and the shot first one goes wide and
and just a shot on towards the net glances
off a stick or the back end of the pants
right there of Dakota murmus and then you
see merold try to SW at it as well but ra
over to Steel who fires it not to the short
side list will curl off in the corner run
the clock down of the Dallas Stars sweep
the three Game season series in convincing
fashion for the Minnesota Wild tonight 7- two